[Captions by Y Translator]
Today, our video
is sponsored by NordVPN.
In today's video, we're trying
a spy movie trick
to see if we can make an
impression of a key in clay,
and then make our own copy based
on that impression.
[Music]
Calli, have you
ever seen a movie
where someone makes a copy of
a key by pressing it into clay,
and then having their own
version of the key later?
I've heard of one or two.
Yeah.
I'm pretty sure
I've seen that movie too,
and we have a common request
from YouTube user
Purple Pewdiepie asking
if we can try casting
a gallium key in the sand.
Here's the basic idea.
We'll take a key
that opens a padlock,
make a mold using some clay,
and then use so gallium
to cast a copy of our own.
Purple Pewdiepie,
we want to try this idea.
Although, we are going
to change it up a little bit.
Instead of using sand,
like we've used for casting
some stuff in the past,
we're going to try
using an oil-based clay.
Clay, you're going to get
much better resolution.
When we're trying
to cast that key,
we need all
of those fine details,
and all of those teeth.
Clay is going to give us
what we need.
Sand can be
fairly fine resolution,
but clay is made from just
the absolute smallest,
finest, silt-like particles,
and so, this is going to get us
like a really accurate result,
and if we want a working key,
I think we need
the best detail.
We've got a treasure chest.
It has a lock on it,
and we have a key.
So I mean,
we can already get inside.
But the point is we want to see
what would happen
if like in movies,
you only have
a couple of seconds,
maybe you manage to pick
someone's pocket or something.
You have their keychain.
You have that key
for just a minute.
Just how long do you need
to have their key before you
can take an impression of it,
and then make
your own copy later?
This is an oil
based sculpting clay,
and it does a really good job
of picking up details,
but it's also very rigid
to the point where it's
actually kind of hard to get
an impression in it right now.
It needs to be warmed up
before it's soft enough
that we can do stuff with it.
The easiest way to do that,
toss it in the microwave.
Now, if this were water
based clay, first off,
you wouldn't want
to be doing this.
Usually it's a coarser grit,
but also, you can't put
in the microwave.
It would not really dry,
it kind of explodes.
Don't do that.
Oil-based clay.
This is a really
good way of warming up.
Just don't get it too hot.
That's so much better.
That is squishy.
It comes completely squishes
apart in your hands.
That's what we're looking for.
We're good to go.
We're trying now to get
a nice flat smooth surface
on one side of the clay.
That's going to help
us get a better mold.
Although, we are just going
to be smooshing it a lot,
so it may or may not make
too much of a difference.
Once we've got the key cast,
we're going to need
a way to fill it,
and with some kind of metal,
you can just pour it in.
But a key doesn't leave
a lot of space,
so we're probably going
to want something that can force
the metal down into the mold,
and my thought is
that we can use this little
plastic dosing syringe.
It will suck up
the liquid gallium,
so I think,
we first need to take
our little syringe here,
and mold a spot
for it into the clay,
and then we'll line up the key.
We're going to be pressing these
two pieces of clay together.
But if we normally just
take two pieces of clay,
and press them together,
it's sort of just becomes
one piece of clay.
It's doesn't like
to come back apart.
Really easy way to separate
that is just using
some baby powder.
We'll sprinkle it
over the surface of the clay.
Then when we press
our pieces back together,
we can pull them
apart very easily.
[Music]
Now, we've got
our syringe marking.
That's where we're going
to be able to put
our dosing syringe in,
and inject the metal
right into it.
And now, time to do the key.
Just to make sure though,
let's reapply the baby powder.
>> Just a little bit.
Kinda align the key up,
so that the top of it intersects
with where the syringe will be.
That way, we should have
a direct channel
to fill this thing.
[Music]
Pretty well lined up,
and now, go for it.
Just smoosh it.
You don't want it
to slip at all.
In fact, if we want to stop
the slipping a little bit,
we can just take some
of the edges, and pinch
them together a little bit.
That should keep
it from sliding.
All right.
So we've got this as pressed
and as well formed
as we can without
it slipping anywhere,
but the clay is still so soft.
It's malleable.
So if we were
to peel these apart,
it would still work.
So what we want to do is
we want to make this clay
just as hard as it was before.
Best way to do that,
bucket of ice water.
[Music]
It should cool down
pretty quick actually.
Scalpel.
Let's see what we got.
[Music]
All right.
I made these little score lines
on the side, and hopefully,
we'll be able to use those
to line up in backup.
But before we put it
back together and try
and fill with metal,
there's another step
we need to take.
If I try and inject
the metal right into this,
it's just not going
to go anywhere because the air
won't have any way to get out.
So I'm going to use a knife
and carved just
a little air channel.
Hopefully, that will let all
of our gallium get out.
And now, to help
hold everything together,
and to keep gallium
from leaking out, just pinch
closed all of the clay gaps.
There's a good chance we'll get
a little bit of flashing,
but this should minimize it.
Flashing is when you get
the casting material,
leaving the edges
that are supposed
to be defined by the mold.
I want to be able to squish
the clay back down.
But if I press in the middle,
it's just going
to collapse the key,
and then we'll never get
anything usable out of it.
You've got our gallium
that still liquid,
but it's not very warm.
Like at this point,
it's probably about
on the point of turning back
and start getting some crystals,
which is good because it means
it should solidify faster.
I'll try.
[Music]
I think that's
actually in there.
And now, what we're going
to do is just put this back
in the ice water and
let it cool down.
While Nate waits
for the gallium to cool down,
why don't we talk
about Nord VPN,
our sponsor for this video?
Okay, but I have iMessaging.
I get the blue bubbles.
I can replace the battery
in my phone if I need do.
I get better apps faster
than you do.
I have a headphone jack.
I'm an Android.
And I'm an iPhone.
There is one thing that
we can agree on however.
That is true, NordVPN.
NordVPN, it's a
virtual private network.
It protects your devices,
it protects all of them.
Android, iPhone, PC,
Apple, they all work
and your internet is safe.
Guys, if you're ever
in a place where you
don't trust the internet,
if you're traveling,
if you're in a hotel and you're
not sure about that Wi-Fi,
you want to be
working through NordVPN.
They have got servers
in over 61 countries.
Those servers are super fast
and the best part is,
if you don't like it,
there's a risk free 30 day
money-back guarantee.
There's other cool uses too.
It works by rerouting
your internet through a server
in a different country.
It lets you access
parts of the internet
that may be blocked
where you are.
For instance, you can watch
some streaming services
that may be different
in one country or another.
You can use peer
to peer file-sharing
without having to worry
about what's being monitored.
So just in time for the busiest
shopping days of the year,
we have got an amazing deal
to keep you safe online,
For a limited time,
get 75% off of a three-year plan
at NordVPN.com/random.
This special offer makes your
subscription $2.99 per month,
so you can browse securely.
On all of your devices,
and for a short time,
use code random to get
an extra month for free.
You punched your phone.
You've just been browsing
cat pictures this whole time?
Yeah, they're NordVPN.
[Music]
Most definitely is key shape.
It does look mostly like a key.
We did get some flashing,
this right here is what
I was talking about.
That's flashing.
It's when it just expands
beyond where it's supposed to,
but I think we might be able
to get that to work.
[Music]
We have a key shape,
and it's really not bad,
but I don't think it's clean
enough to open the lock.
Yeah, there's just,
there's little bits of flashing
and just part sticking out,
and I think we just clean
it up with file.
A little bit will get
a usable result.
[Music]
Okay, I think...
Ready for test?
I think we're good.
Here it goes.
[Music]
Key fits.
It went in.
[Music]
Lock is popped!
With a gallium key...
That is nuts.
It twisted.
It did.
It actually bend.
The key is just very
slightly corkscrewed.
Bend.
Be straightened.
Wonder if it's just
like getting too warm,
we'll put it back
in the ice water.
[Music]
You can do it!
Oh my gosh!
It is done
for but we did it.
We got a few opens
with this key,
but I think it has had it.
So can you cast a key
out of gallium?
You can cast a key
out of gallium.
Making the mold of it,
if you had clay,
you could smoosh the key
into the mold really quick.
You need some baby powder too
to keep it from getting ruined.
But we also found
that it helped a lot to just
throw it in the ice water,
so as you're peeling it apart,
it didn't completely deform.
Two or three minutes tops.
I mean that's maybe longer
than you would ideally want
if you were a spy stealing a key
something from someone, but...
Still works.
It works.
We didn't want to try
that with a car
because if this broke off
in a car's ignition,
it's kind of a bigger problem.
If it breaks off
inside the master lock,
not the end of the world.
Probably can just
metal too right out.
[Music]
Nate, here you go.
I made that for you.
The key is still in the lock.
It's mostly still in the lock.
Okay, but what was
in the treasure chest?
[Music]
It's a King of Random kit.
Wow, I wanted one of these.
Thanks again to Purple Pewdieiie
for this awesome idea.
Don't forget to
check your inbox,
for we're going to be
sending you 25 bucks.
Thanks again to our sponsor
for this video, NordVPN.
Guys, click the link
in the description below
to start protecting yourself
while you're online.
Guys, that's not all,
we've always got more
for you to see.
This box up here at the top will
take you to our latest video.
The box down at the bottom is
what YouTube thinks you
should be watching next,
and if you're not subscribed
hit that bomb in the middle,
then don't forget
to click that bell so you
never miss out on the fun.
We'll talk to you
in the next one.
See you then.